the terror network of Brussels and its
central figure saleh abdeslam for months
the french national had been hiding the
belgian capital after officials accused
him of participating the paris attacks
last november just days before the
bombings in Brussels police arrested at
Islam but during questioning he revealed
no information on the planned attacks
Melissa papa louie louie takes after
shlom held close contact with all four
of the brussels bombers the two brothers
khalid and ibrahim paco we were already
wanted for international authorities the
Belgian police failed to arrest them
during a series of raids in Brussels
last week both brothers flew themselves
up during the attacks the younger one
college in a metro station where 14
people died
the third attacker named l'ho we had
received bomb-making training in Syria
he was a key figure in the group lihue
fingerprints were also found in an
apartment used to assemble a suicide
vest for the performance he died at
brussels airport along with 17 civilians
there's a fourth as yet unidentified
person he was also at the airport but
unable to detonate his explosive device
his whereabouts are still unknown and
Belgian authorities face growing
pressure to deliver on the investigation
situation in Brussels is still going on
they are still a lot of investigation
now in Brussels so it may be too early
to say it's finished finally authorities
suggest that both Abdeslam and how we
have been regular contact with this man
abdelhamid abaaoud the mastermind behind
the attacks in Paris a bow would was
raised like Abdeslam in molenbeek a
suburb of Brussels which has become
notorious for radicalization an active
terror cells banning both France and
Belgium according to experts in network
of 40 to 50 individuals some are now
dead two are at large up to 15 in prison
authorities say how many others are
still active in the background is
unclear